the Church of what's happening now
Monday the day the devil was very to see
you've [ __ ] in the ass lit on fire and
dropped off the Cosby's out oh [ __ ] Owen
Benjamin what's up
police syad uncle Joey get those shoes
on [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] pump off those moves [ __ ]
but what what's the story Lisa oh my god
these stars are kicking in faster we're
not [ __ ] around fermenting these you
know I'm saying these have been sitting
at the dock all in Benjamin what's
happened just the stars are kicking in
pretty high up yeah and I wouldn't even
let you eat the second one because I
know these things smack people around
really hard
since college so I was always traveling
so I never really looked forward to more
it's almost like our job is People's
Party so it's like you don't live in the
frat house you know you kind of just
can't go Owen Benjamin just gave me a
look that I recognize it's a look that's
telling me crazy I yeah it's let's hit
yeah yeah I'm sorry
no but it's cool like all your story
won't water because you're such a
descriptive talker that everything
you're saying I'm like literally seeing
in my head it's really fun
only we feelin alright yeah I'm John
gets a man yeah now I'm I'm [ __ ] crazy
how though
okay your low blow water yeah okay do
some water yeah [ __ ] I told you you
won't lead to I saved you because I like
that
well that his voice changed a little bit
and I know he stays in a lot more sure
madness the end of those things is
strong
yeah you just relax this is the devil
how can you handle six because we're
training on Benjamin and Owen Benjamin
coming back he's coming back he's making
a comeback like Jerry Lewis this is good
[ __ ] these stars the stars at that power
Benjamin you wanna take a walk you're
right
get some air right there get Samantha
back and take your water with you just
in case you [ __ ] you know you want to
be hydrate a little bit you'll be all
right
this happens is they have to do a
thousand things little stupid [ __ ] is
the real deal the church you know as a
matter of fact I'm gonna bag them
another one other respect for this poor
kid okay we think I'm not even alone
I'll respect for you people you know I
love you at all my heart I hope you have
a good week I mean this darn [ __ ]
solo tip just to let you know we ain't
[ __ ] around no more take it a [ __ ]
leave it I ain't got time for this [ __ ]
no more your attitude should be like my
attitude it's over we're taking over
this [ __ ] right or wrong [ __ ]
I really think on Benjamin abandoned
[ __ ] he's the first guest that has ever
been breathing I don't know I think he's
out I could see it there was one point
where I could see his eye just go thank
God he said no one the Tiger one yeah he
would have been dead
I want to thank own Benjamin these stars
are [ __ ] brutal
you